good morning John the year was 2007 and
I put a picture of a giraffe in the
thumbnail of a video it was actually
just an image from a book I probably
still have the book actually it was this
book birds and bees and the image was
this one just a couple of giraffes
having a time back then the way YouTube
worked you didn't upload your own
thumbnail it just chose the exact middle
of the video and I intentionally held
that picture up as the exact middle of
the video and yeah it got a lot of views
that was followed up by a song in 2008
giraffe love questions in 2009 a
complete introduction to giraffe sex in
2010 and then in 2016 even more
discussion of how giraffes meet but it
has now been more than seven years since
we last discussed giraffes on this
channel it's the longest giraffe drought
we've ever had and I had the thought
it's been such a long time we must have
like as the species found out new things
about giraffes since the last time I
posted a giraffe video and guess what
John it's true there's a bunch of stuff
that we now know about giraffes that we
didn't know when when we last made a
video about giraffes in preparation for
this video I even got to email with a
giraffe scientist who was researching
giraffes right now in Tanzania finding
out things that we don't know about
giraffes so I'm going to hit you with
five things that we didn't know about
giraffes in 2016 but we know them now
starting with how many species of
giraffe there are which is a bit of a
cheat fact because we still don't know
how many species of giraffe there are
but also we kind of can't know how many
species of giraffe there are because
species is like a human idea not
something that nature does but look
giraffes are spread out they exist all
the way from just south of the Sahara to
South Africa that's a bigger distance
than you'd think New York and London are
closer together than giraffes you John
are closer to Brazil than West African
giraffes are to South African giraffes
but a series of whole genome analyzes
showed that we probably should not be
considering giraffes to be one species
there might be three there might be four
there might be five there might be six
but that conversation is super important
because if you count all giraffes as
just giraffes then there's like hundreds
of thousands of giraffes but if you
divide them up into four different
species then some of those species are
very endangered now in 2016 we also
didn't think the giraffes really
vocalized at least not much some people
even thought that they're like necks
were too long for them to make
vocalizations they'd make noises they'd
do like coughs and snorts and Snuffles
and they'd do lots of different
Communications with their heads and
bodies but it was in the last seven
years that we realized that giraffes do
vocalize they just do it at night often
and in a very very low pitched hum which
is an amazing noise that I do not have
access to the copyright of but I will
link it in the description it's a
beautiful noise that you can barely hear
with the human ear and these
vocalizations are part of how giraffes
communicate and maintain their culture
and that's another thing that we've
learned since 2016 is giraffes are
intensely cultural and much smarter and
more social than we thought and one key
thing here is is something that they
actually have in common with people and
something that is very rare in the
animal kingdom giraffes have females
that continue to survive for a long time
after they no longer are able to breathe
like 30 of the lifespan of a female
giraffe is after it is capable of making
babies we see post-reproductive females
in not very many species humans killer
whales some other kinds of whales like
pilot whales I think kind of elephants
though people will argue about elephants
and now giraffes the reason we think
this happens is called the grandmother
hypothesis it's that it happens in
species where information transmission
from older to younger Generations is
really important so like cultural
information like knowledge and
understanding and like it needs to have
a repository in older members of the
social group so that the younger members
can benefit from that indicates that
giraffes are much more social and much
more cultural and have much more
knowledge than we thought they did all
right big shift now because it's time to
talk about blood pressure giraffes as
you might expect have very high blood
pressure because they have to get the
blood to where it needs to go like high
enough blood pressure that if it was
your blood pressure it would damage your
heart to be pushing blood that hard and
so researchers were like it'd be nice if
we figured out what's going on with the
dress maybe we could help uh people not
get damaged Hearts if they have high
blood pressure maybe and they actually
found a gene in the giraffe that seems
to be responsible for some of their
heart's resilience and they took that
Gene and they put it into mice and then
they gave the mice high blood pressure
artificially and the ones who had the
giraffe Gene experienced way less
scarring of their heart when they had
high blood pressure so that's wild I
don't know what we're gonna do with that
but that's wild and finally as we
understand how remarkable giraffes are
how much more social they are and also
that there are a lot of species of them
and also that they're losing a lot of
their habitat and their population is
decreasing quite quickly the
conservation of giraffes becomes even
more important now it used to be
imagined that wildlife and people who
herd animals kind of it exist in
opposition to each other and that is
definitely true to some extent like this
relationship is extremely complicated
but it should also be noted that people
have been hurting in sub-Saharan Africa
for many Millennia and so recently
there's been a lot more research into
not just the antagonistic parts of The
Herder to Wildlife relationship but also
the parts where actually the herding
people might be in some ways good for
the Savannah and for the Wildlife and
certainly when compared with other land
uses like farming or mining or charcoal
production herding is much less
impactful to the Savannah and to the
wildlife populations and so if you do it
right you can actually see a world where
protecting traditional uses of land is
actually also good for wildlife even
though we used to think those things
were really like ultimately strictly in
opposition to each other which I've been
reading about in this book called
savannas of our Birth by Robin Reed it's
not the world's greatest click bait
thumbnail or anything but it is really
good and fascinating and the thing to
remember about all of this information
is that people went out and got it and
that is so it was illustrated by this
book which looks quite long right and it
is but this part is the book and this
part is the notes and references which
that's a lot of references because
there's a lot of people working on this
stuff the scientist I emailed with said
that a lot of times we miss what
giraffes are up to because they do
everything so amazingly slowly but that
doesn't mean that we as a species cannot
do it we just need to watch and to
listen especially to their nearly
subsonic hums John I'll see you on
Tuesday